every guy in here
has felt really proud of himself
because
while they've been peeing they've been
cleaning the toilet
that's a fact every guy in here is like
i'm a
sharpshooter all heroes wear [ __ ]
capes okay there was something dried on
the toilet babe i got it off or there
every guy will admit to that and if you
never did that you're a psychopath
period i cleaned the bathroom
sometimes you got to do the dirty work
that nobody else wants to do and if it's
a little tough little thing you get
closer to it you're like
and i salute those people out there well
done sir
sometimes you push extra hard you're
like huh
oh if you haven't [ __ ] your pants while
you're peeing you haven't lived yet just
that's a questionable comment i don't
know if that's ever happened and if it
has happened to you should have just sat
down while you had a chance if you
haven't [ __ ] your pants while you're
peeing you haven't lived yet just
it's gross we're gross people yeah you
know i don't that's a questionable
experience i don't know if i really
agree with that i don't think i've
won definitely never [ __ ] myself while
peeing because
that just sounds like why are you
pushing so hard that doesn't make any
sense and two i don't think i've ever
[ __ ] myself in my like teenage or adult
life like i'm still on a good streak
here no pun intended and i'm gonna try
and keep that non-streak streak
i think that made sense going i'll give
myself a pass when i hit like 60 because
you know as an elderly person i you know
i may slip up a couple times and that's
gonna be okay no duty in the pants for
my entire adult life until i hit 60 then
we're good it gives call of duty a
different meaning
hey what's going on everybody look
what's up uh
jacob's been doing such a good job
doing reaction videos
about the stories about him i thought
that maybe we should have him do a
reaction video to jokes at worrying
about him you know yeah thanks for
finally writing a joke that's not about
me
okay well this seems like a nice place
to stop it's a nice change of pace
hey everybody looks like uh
i i'm glad you're enjoying these videos
i'll make sure we're doing a podcast
called hey man take us out man uh we do
a podcast called hey man it's just an
easy one we just talk about life we talk
about uh pretty much anything all ins
and outs personal questions funny
stories he also has been admitting
things to me about things that he's done
in when he was a kid that i didn't know
about yeah i told him i took his car out
and did donuts all throughout high
school so it's a joyride in my car
all the time while you were home i would
just even when i was just out getting
groceries i would do it
that's why the eggs came back cracked at
one time
is that right
you
hey but i never crashed your car
okay so we're good yeah that's probably
true fair enough um
but yeah these videos have been so much
fun man we've been having a lot of fun
just you know getting into it and
finally getting to tell my side of the
story is always uh always nice so i
finally get to get out there and defend
myself
but thank you guys so much for watching
this has been a ton of fun we can't wait
to put out some more stuff uh on youtube
make sure you hit the subscribe button
hit the like leave a comment and make
sure you hit that notification button so
you can see when our new stuff goes live
and for the podcast as well guys i know
you hear this out of everybody you hear
it a million times every time someone
does a podcast you hear it at the end
but truthfully if you like it and you
rate us and you leave a comment it means
the absolute so much means people ask
all the time how can we support
there you go that's it and i know look
you hear from people all the time then
there's probably out of the 10 000
podcasts you you do it for four we're
just asking to be one of the four and we
appreciate you guys are thank you jets
beating the buccaneers
sorry but again thank you guys so much
go to youtube subscribe like comment the
notification button all that good stuff
uh and we can't wait to put all this
stuff in the new year 2022 is gonna be
gonna be a whole lot of fun come check
us out on the road too comedian
comedianjoshwolf.com i'm bringing this
dude with me
we have a good time out there we got a
date coming up in january i think we're
doing columbus funny bone january 28th
and 29th come see us let's have some fun
let's get weird later later
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]